Takumi, now I understand Shifu Dojima's thoughts.
Imagine the next time, like when you've supported the total amount so far
[Music]
First of all, have you passed the first
hurdle?  Physicality You're a support, you're the
one who can pick up on good things and make unreasonable lattes.
There's nothing like 6 or 2. If
you wave your hand like this, it's going to be black.
I can't even talk about it, people are eating it lol
But why is my father cooking like a woman?
Meat Sauce When
you go to the watershed, the flavored vegetables are thoroughly
browned, and red wine and bouillon are used to create a vivid crispness and richness.
I wonder if I can't proceed with the royal road procedure It's my
birthday and I'm running I shouldn't use such ingredients for this dish
Besides, that salloh parmentier is usually served in a gratin dish in French homes It's served on
a plate  In other words,
we are trying to create a
wide-angle restaurant scene in Futima, Dojima City
.